[Music]
w
sweet Mary your beauty shines you are
the Wonder in my eyes I just want to be
the made so choose
meet I'm make you s I'll s you tce I'll
do the move that makes you
smile I just want to take your hand and
[Music]
show
oh
I didn't know what to title this
video winter in Washington
maybe but the truth is I've barely
scratched the surface of all there is to
see
here especially during these colder
snowier
months
this feels more like a kind of in
between it's that gray space where
you've outgrown the life you're living
but haven't quite worked out what comes
[Music]
next
I'm here in Washington during the
darkest coldest months of the
year because
I want to see if this is where I really
want to
be if Washington
Feels Like
Home
CL
we're up at Steven's Pass and it is 5°
outside how cold is think it is now it's
got to be about
zero I can't feel my fingers or my
butt that's when you know it's
cold but it's fun though I enjoy
[Music]
it
woo
[Music]
br
for
I've been in Washington for nearly 7
weeks staying at a house sit just
outside of Seattle
watching after a golden doodle named
Marlo the owners are cool with taking
Marlo on overnight
Adventures which is how we landed here
at the Pacific
bin my friend Devin designed and built
this place from the ground up using
stacked storage
containers and it's absolutely
stunning
when Devon invited Marlo and I to spend
a few nights out here I knew it would be
beautiful but it was actually more than
that it got me dreaming
[Music]
and
thinking
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you like it here do you like it here
yes
[Music]
the house I've been looking after in
Seattle is spacious modern and in a
neighborhood I'm most definitely cannot
afford it's been really nice just being
in one
place and I told myself that I'd rent an
apartment once the sit was
over if I felt compelled to
stay but so far I haven't felt that
way until I came
here
waking up every day surrounded by trees
and just knowing that mountains and
rivers and forested trails are all
around
me it makes my heart so
[Music]
happy
I want the
dream to pick me up when I'm
falling give me the Dream House with
enough
space to hi away when I'm all
it after spending time out here and at
the house sit I find myself thinking
more and more about buying
land and building a
house financially it's really
intimidating it also doesn't help that I
have zero experience with either one but
I'm feeling inspired to at least explore
the
idea on our last day Devon invited us
over to see his latest project the cedar
Hollow it's a 400t cabin on the same
property and still in the building
stage and my first thought when walking
in was yeah I could definitely live
[Music]
here I want the dream life with enough
things to pick me up when I'm
falling give me the Dream House with
space to hide away when I'm
[Music]
all so for the past few
weeks I've been looking for
land and learning as much as I
can about zoning surveys County rules
and
regulations the cost of running
electricity drilling a well laying a
driveway it's all slightly
terrifying but also really
exciting which is usually a good
thing
for
so I'm just going to put this wish out
into the
universe if you or anyone you know would
be interested in selling land that is at
least 1 acre ideally closer to
five with forest and maybe even a
Mountain View here in Washington
State
I would love to hear from
you I know it's probably a shot in the
dark but hey a girl can
[Music]
dream
here